all right
are we getting started are we ready
i'm just gonna say yes hey everyone if
we can have
um the cast and the creative
come on screen of
all the mezzo shows so we can applaud
you
thanks for joining us
um if you can just when you come on um
if you can just say your name
and the show you were part of if you're
obviously part of more than one this
season as well
let's start with you tavia
uh my name's tavia hunt and i was
a part of blessings and i read stage
directions
for daughters of the confederacy me
sorry
i'm maul i was a part of blessings
as you saw
my name is tyler cruz i was i read stage
directions for
blessings and i played alexandra in
daughters of the confederacy
hi my name is nomae i
was baraka in blessings yes
alexander oh hi i'm alexandra
and i was a part of blessings
oh that's gone
tyler i went
sorry
johnny uh hi
i'm johnny i was a part of
daughters of the confederacy i played
william warpol
meriwether
hi all um i'm on the love uh i read for
private bets
in where pathways meet by ak payne so
good to be here
shame hey hi i'm shayum
uh i play dwight in where the pathways
meet by
ak pain
and then let's hear from our directors
and our tech team
edmund are you here we want to say thank
you too if you're here
yay
hey so i'm edmund uh and i
stage managed all three of
the readings for summer cats
hi i'm alex i directed blessings and i'm
one of the co-artistic directors of the
summer cabaret
hi i'm christopher betts i'm one of the
co-artist directors of the summer
cabaret i directed
daughters of the confederacy and where
pathways meet
i'm liam and i designed sound for the
season and abigail i think
yes hi i'm sorry i'm abigail i am
of the one of the actors for aka payne's
play
uh where pathways meet as well as um
angie bridgette jones the daughters of
the confederacy
um thank you so much everyone
congratulations on an amazing
mezza summer season you all work so hard
oh we have a guest
hey kay you just want to introduce
yourself and your name
and the play hi yeah i'm ak pain i wrote
where pathways me
amazing um i was just saying thank you
everyone and congratulations to the cast
and thank you to the audience for
sticking with us we really appreciate it
i'm ashley thomas i'm nicole moderator
along with our lovely she's to the side
of me but
faith zombley our other wonderful
co-moderator so the way this is going to
work is
we're going to ask some questions we're
going to talk to the cast and the
creative and then we'll open it up for q
and a's so you'll have a chance to also
ask everyone questions as well
and we just want to have a good time and
celebrate this evening so
we're going to kick it off um we'd like
to thank one of our
sponsors the yale center for race
indigeneity
and transnational migration they sent in
some questions which is really exciting
and um we'll kick it off with them
thanks so much ashley for that
introduction hello
everyone thank you all for coming again
um
and thank you all who are on this
channel i'm really excited to talk to
you
um so the first question is pretty broad
so you can answer it however you want um
but it felt important to acknowledge the
material conditions
like the fact that we're in a pandemic
and the fight for black lives is
continuing in the streets right now
um and so one of the things that i
wanted to ask is how did the
creation of this work shift um
because of those external conditions
um do you feel like you
were freer to explore questions of race
and identity
or more limited um this is a super
general question to get started but
i guess i'm what i'm really asking is
how
did these events shape your process as
you were making this work
that's a tricky one to answer um
uh but i think for me
especially working on this one which was
clearly in response to like
a very specific um
event but also many events
uh that are similar i think coming into
it
it felt like in my experience it felt
like
myself along with the other actors and
like all the creative team we were like
speaking the same language and like i
felt like
it actually was like very aligning and
like
very unifying especially being in a cast
that was like
made up of entirely like black women
pretty much and like i think so yeah in
my experience i i found it like
very like grounding um and yeah it felt
like
we were sort of all on the same page in
terms of like
not in terms of like our healing and
like our activism or even really like
our understanding
or like processing of what is going on
but certainly like
in um holding space for one another and
like in allowing for
whatever needed to come up and that felt
um very new and like
unique to my creative process at least
i don't know if that answers the
question
um yeah something that
was incredibly resonant for me was um
there's specific lines and text in in
ak's play
that uh metaphorically refer to things
that happen
in our history i think minnie has a line
and
and um abigail if you could uh correct
me
where they say where she says um
uh she lists names of people that have
been
um killed and lost their lives you know
um at the hands of police brutality or
or whoever um
but i you know that was incredibly
resonant for me because i think that
you know that was something that was
very very specific and um
depend it didn't matter what time we
were talking about it
um you know it was something that was
very real for us um
on the moon in uh where the pathways
meet and
you know there are other references too
that um aka has
um that refer to things that happen on
planet earth um
but there are there are small
metaphorical things in the play that
um you know really resonated with me um
and gave me just a great point of
connection
[Music]
let's hear from maybe one more before we
move on
um i think in a lot of ways uh i've been
thinking a lot about like how this
particular moment shapes like the work
that a lot of black writers are doing
um and how um like the struggle has
always continued and the way in which
like
black life has been a target for so much
violence is like not a new thing
um but i think that in this time i'm
really grateful for the sort of
space to talk about it in a global like
broader sense
and the way in which like there seems to
be a collective movement
to like fight and hear black voices in a
way that like feels
different than past times at least to me
and i think for me that gave me space as
i was revising where pathways meet for
this
to revise in a way that was reflective
of that space
um if that makes sense and and and and
with more grace because of that space
um but yeah i do think that there's
something
about like a continuous struggle uh that
like is important to acknowledge that
like the work is
is ongoing and not new
thank you for that um so just a reminder
we're gonna ask questions and then we'll
open it up for questions from the
audience through the q
a function so thank you so much for
everyone for being with us
um the next question that came from the
yale center for race indigeneity
and transnational migration is um what
do you imagine the afterlifes of these
works
i i know this isn't traditional theater
this is zoom theater i joke and say now
we go to zoom university
but how do you all imagine and imagine
these works
existing and how do you imagine yourself
participating
and theater works that exist in this
digital
space that we're in right now
i think that for me i loved all three
plays uh
so deeply that working on them through
zoom
it was so funny because i i i know when
i was directing i kept pushing them to
the limit of
what zoom can be and trying to embrace
um
what zoom can be um and it really really
made me hanker
for to like put the shows up on their
feet i think especially
um in angie's play there's so much
physical comedy up in that play
and i think that a lot of humor was able
to be found because we could not be
physical and we had to do things
through a camera and like sort of
leaning into that medium really worked
for that play but
there was still a hunger i still have a
hunger to see all three of these plays
up on their feet and to work on these
plays up on their feet because
um i think that they're all incredibly
theatrical and they demand to be
theatricalized
and you know that is that is not what
zoom is so when i have work that
when i come across work that demands to
be theatricalized that makes me want to
put it on a stage
so while i feel like we reached what we
could through this medium given this
medium and given the
current state of our world it made me
very hungry to see
these productions have a full these uh
plays have a full life with full
production
and tech and costumes i also just like
all of that stuff i like give me the
give me the set give me the budget give
me all that so of course i want to see
it like that
but i think that these three plays in
general demand that
um so if no one else has anything that
they want to add
although you can feel free to stop me if
you do um i'm going to move this to the
next question
um which sort of relates to the one that
came
before which is what has the experience
of
working on zoom working in these
interesting times
taught you about theater making that
perhaps you would want to take with you
going forward um and how do you think it
will affect the way that
you approach work in the future
and maybe there's nothing and what
you've learned is that you hate zoom
which is also an acceptable answer
i think that zoom really helped push my
imagination
um you know creating
the world of the play in you know your
tight space and imagining that you're
talking to this person that's
you know supposed to be right in front
of you even though even though you're
looking at the green dot like
for me i really had to set the space
um and also kind of you know take time
to just know where i
am in the world of the play and really
really focus on
what is happening outside of this small
box
that is affecting me um at first it was
very hard like
it was difficult i did not like it at
all
but you know i over time i started to
kind of like
um you know for lack of a better word
experiment
you know with what i could create around
me and how those things could affect me
um
you know especially in a case play where
there's so many things that happen
in front of us like the magic and you
know the
the hammer being created and the rocks
the stones turning into
um whatever they were turning into and
the rain it just
forced me to really use my imagination
in ways that i i don't think i've ever
done
before on stage because it usually
happens right
there in front of you whether it's with
lights or sound or anything like that
yeah and to add on to what um sharon
said
was is that um i think an interesting
thing about
um um zoom is that there's no excuses
like you there's no budget there's no
nothing you you
just have an opportunity to be able to
be like if i want to put up a black clay
and i want to make it as black as i want
you know um
this medium is a perfect medium for you
to do it
um it's it's uh definitely
made it a lot easier for me as
a performer and as a writer to kind of
be like i just want to put something up
and i could just call up some of my
friends and be like
hey can you read this and can we just do
like a little zoom production real quick
and there we go we have a play in a
matter of seconds
um and so i think that this medium
really does
open doors for if you're
if you decide tomorrow that you want to
start writing
your heart out and that you want to put
up some stuff
you can have your mom be an actor and
it'll it'll work
it'll work so um i i think that that
it is it's exhausting zoom fatigue is a
thing it's very exhausting but
i think it's worth it in the long run
i also think that zoom
is interesting because you obviously
don't have one of the elements
that's uh pretty critical to live
theater which is like
an audience but i like an audience that
like you are
breathing the same air and within the
same space
um but i think in my
like limited experience with zoom
theater it's like really made me
like reaffirm and like reconnect with
like my
personal like process and like
preparation and also like my engagement
with my scene partner
so that i'm not like relying on like
validation that i might receive
from like people laughing or like or
what whatever it is and like obviously
that's great and like
i said something funny but like i think
like
i don't know there's something really
like wonderful and i think also to like
uh abigail's point something that's
really freeing about just like
being in this space where there isn't
either the validation or like if you
perceive it as judgment or like
or whatever it is and so it feels like a
little bit
like you can like cut it up more and
like
that's really strange and i think it's
also sort of made me think a lot about
like how i want to
engage in my work like once i'm back in
a studio and like back with my peers and
like back in an audience and like
what can i what from that release and
like that freedom
can i hang on to um so that i'm no
longer
feeling like i'm having to um
like rely on sort of for me
sometimes it is like that like
validation or that
yeah that like energy from an audience
and i'll say too uh honestly
zoom acting is really hard i think it's
completely
different than what we're trained to do
like we kind of have to go against
everything that we're taught as actors
but the thing that i actually do
appreciate about zoom
is like it kind of goes back to the
basics of
for me i realize it's like an incredible
um
act of like faith and trust because all
we really have
are the playwright's words so for me
like going through this process i was
like okay if i just trust
the playwright's words and because i
don't have
the stimulation that i would have in a
live theater space
like trusting the words that i have in
front of me
trusting my own imagination trusting my
company even though
we're not connected in the same ways
that we would be
in a live setting i feel like there is
something about zoom acting that
does bring it back to the basics of
relying on the language relying on the
text to give me everything that i need
and kind of simplifying which i actually
do appreciate
i'm just to say something about what
alex just said
uh that's what i'm really excited to
explore in the future is because
when you're on here you have to find a
different way to uh
connect and what you just said about the
language is like
how you say something is your only form
of connect to you that's the only way
they're gonna receive
anything from you you know what i mean
because when you're doing a zoom play
a lot of the times you have to go back
and forth between a script
so how many times do you actually have
the opportunity to look
at the person that usually comes a bit
after there's a lot of technicality that
comes to doing stuff on here
and so i think uh bringing it back down
to language
and then once all of this is over having
to come back in person with somebody
you literally had to expand
your notion of connection you don't have
body
you don't have these other things so i
think it'll i think it'll hurt
for a lot of us when we get back in
person with people
because now we can't just um you know
punk out and rely on five other things
you know we've been through that storm
already we can do something else now
so
thank you so much here i think that's a
perfect place to wrap up this question
and um i just want to welcome you to the
call
would you mind um introducing yourself
we have
angie jones on the call and i think we
have anthony brown
also logged in so if you want mine just
waving
saying your name um the play you were
associated with
and we'll move on to the next question
okay i can go hello hi excuse my uh
tardiness my cpt my name is angie
brijette jones
i am the playwright of daughters of
confederacy i am also a capricorn
and uh house ravenclaw so hope that
helps
hi everybody uh i'm anthony i play
jackson where pathways meet
uh by ak directed by christopher yeah
glad to be here sorry i'm late
i'm like wi-fi issues
and then sierra i'm not sure what
character you play though
sorry all right so i'm sierra um
then daughters of the confederacy and i
play meriwether
thank you all so much so alexandra your
point about
not being connected with people leads me
to my next question um
dealing with connectedness being so
tuned in all the time you're tuned in
new zoom rehearsal
day in day out you're looking at your
computer for the script
and that inadvertently may lead you to
looking at the news and then checking
social media
so how did you all protect yourselves
your physical
and mental health during these pandemics
uh you know as in all mediums and i say
we're living in three
pandemics if you're a black woman you
know so how did you really
protect yourself during these stressful
times
wait the question was how did we protect
ourselves
during during the rehearsal period how
did you just protect your physical
and mental health i would i would like
to say laughing for myself
um because if i don't laugh at something
why am i here you know i just
laughing and trying to find a little bit
of joy and poking fun
at this thing through the computer like
there was this one really fun moment
where um
abigail has to pop back on screen with
something
in her hand and that was just uh the
highlight of my week because
we all started popping back the screen
during rehearsal with like
hot sauce a freaking uh roller rack
just stupid just something god give me
something so laughter
well um i've been taking use of uh
yale health's uh counseling and therapy
so that's what i've been doing uh once a
week to just protect myself
um getting it all out once a week and
trying to you know apply it to my life
you know
apply to the craft and just
move through this transitional period
with ease
so that's what's been helping me lately
i don't know if my um answer will
i don't know if it answers you directly
but uh i feel like
i haven't been protected in a sense of
like
what am i doing to take care of myself
and it's felt more of
um it just feels like
an ongoing continuous period of
growth and change and confronting a lot
about myself and where i'm at in life
and
you know it's it's so it kind of feels
like just standing
um i don't know in front of like a
massive wave
that feels like what 2020
is right now um but kind of connecting
that to zoom
uh when it had started kind of like what
shane mentioned it was really hard but
um a couple of months in i'm
i'm beginning to accept uh
i don't know this big advantage of it
which
uh is uh sorry um the reality of things
is uh if you know i need to leave the
country soon
but i can still continue working with
people that i know
people that i've trained with um and
that's a nice
reminder and it's also a reminder of
responsibility
that you aren't disconnected at any
given point from your community from
people that you can take support
comfort from as hard as it may be to
reach out for that
um so yeah so zoom is kind of like a
double-edged sword like you can't get
away from it but also there's so much
that you can do with it
at any given point um i don't know how
that relates to
protecting oneself i think i'm still
figuring that one out
something that's also been you know i
mean the pandemic has been
horrible y'all better be wearing your
masks
but it's it's been
good for me in the sense that like i
can't work towards ambition anymore
um and i can only work towards
like personal internal growth and
because because i mean things are shut
down right now like i can't be ambitious
and say
oh i'm gonna go make these connections
and you know go out there and audition
for this thing
in a way it's still happening but it's
given me a lot of time to just like
reflect and think about you know the
type of people the type of person i am
the people i want to surround myself
with
um and that in a in a way has given me
room to actually just like grow um
sans the the acting ambition
part of it um and i think that's been
really helpful for me
i've i can honestly say that like this
summer has
has changed me a lot um only because of
the fact that i've given myself that
time to actually reflect and
and find that personal growth it's been
healing
i'll say for me um
y'all it's hard it's so hard but
something recently that has been
really life-changing in a way
um is me connecting to this idea of like
self-compassion
and um honoring however i feel
unapologetically and also honoring and
expressing what it is that i need
not only for myself but from other
people
so if that means there's a moment where
i need to prioritize black joy
if i need to um have a moment of
stillness or silence if i need to like
dance or
you know having things around me um that
support whatever i'm feeling and and to
honor it
first and foremost without apology
without guilt or shame
and then also like this having a sense
of community because i think that's
been one of the hardest parts is all of
the ways i think
i'm used to coping with certain things
have to do with relating to other people
and now that that's kind of been removed
how do i how do i replace
that feeling of community which is so
important to me
through like other mediums so you know
like
doing free yoga classes or
therapy and checking in with people that
i love
and you know whatever i could possibly
do
just honoring however i feel and what i
need in that moment
and then going from there
thank you so much for that um this
question is going to be the last one
before we open up to the q
a um i'm going to switch tasks a little
bit
and i wanted to ask you all um because
so many of these plays deal with
freedom and what it means to live
a good life or a happy life
and all of the things that sometimes
stand in the way of black people being
able to access those
um ways of being in the world i wanted
to ask you all
what does freedom look like for you as
performers as directors writers
creatives um stage managers
uh what does which could mean what does
freedom look like in your industry
specifically
or what freedom looks like for you
personally
um but yeah i would just love to
hear from you all like what is the world
that you
are imagining
freedom look like looks like um visually
i see more viola davises on stage
i see more um i see
more people with different accents
different languages
uh different skin tone different body
types
um that is not the stereotypical
hollywood
look on stage on film
um i see uh
black playwrights on a daily
um bringing stuff up i see black
directors
i see people of color everywhere like
my mind it's like the that that kind of
freedom to know that like
i can be the actor that goes out into
the world and knows that
somebody is going to want my body um
as a performer period is what i see
as like a free liberating actor's
life you know yeah
i think oh oh everybody was ready to
answer that one go ahead say
oh uh short i think
um for me something
that i found really freeing about this
play that i just worked on and something
that i would love
to see expressed more fully is just like
putting a name to a thing like i feel
like just like
i don't know like with all of these
plays like we're we're like
naming these things that are often so
like hidden or like
coveted or they're like really softened
or they're
uh they're shared like hyperbolically
or it's like things that we are like as
black people and especially as black
women are meant to
express or are can socialize to express
um you know shame about and like
i find it like so freeing to just be
able to like put a name to the thing and
to say like this is what's happening and
like
that's incredibly
like affirming and like liberating and
like exciting and so
yeah just to be able to like boldly
stand in like our truths as
black americans and definitely as black
women
um that that's what comes to mind for me
um i think being able to
survive and create art like on our own
terms when i say r i mean like all the
different ways the black diaspora exists
and shows up
without necessarily being limited uh
based on capitalism and based on the way
that capitalism like manipulates our
stories
um and like makes us have to perform for
white gays and spectatorship
um so yeah that's what it looked like
for me and then i think a part of that
is form
and how we can undo form um as a writer
and as as playwrights um thinking about
how we can find our own structures that
like
we we've known for a long time that um
yeah that have been silenced and and
erased from us
and a lot of the colonial histories
something that feels spring to me is
the border between art forms kind of
going away
um i
should tag on to the last questions like
some a way that i found a lot of
self-care is like
by investing in other black artists
michaela cole and easter
and like all of the people who are where
i want to be um
and something i really appreciate about
them is
that the policing that other people do
or try to place upon them um has not
stopped them from moving
in the world and that's something that
um
i get police a lot so i'm very so
freedom for me
looks like i can't stop the policing
from happening but i can at least stop
myself from being affected by it
um and just being able to like not just
be an actor but to also be able to write
to direct to produce and to find like a
home in
all of those mediums fluidly
y'all are so poetic because like soon as
i heard the question i was like oh
mcdonald's in bugs life that's what
freedom looks like to me like i
specifically on a serious note i think
freedom really just looks like being
unable to do things without anyone
asking you to like to
explain it like honestly like i get
really bogged down
specifically in the realms of like the
pressures of institutions and white
supremacy of being
told over and over again what are you
doing and i'm like i
i was doing the same thing i was doing
every day
but it's because it's weird because uh i
think in the realm of like yo that we
all
are and they're like oh i came in here
doing the weird quirky black girl [ __ ]
that everyone said
that i was supposed to be doing and then
as soon as i get here everyone's asked
me like why are you doing that weird
black girl that well y'all told me to do
the thing that y'all told me to do at
the school so i guess like the freedom
that i look like is being
able to do whatever i want to do without
anyone asking me to do i mean like god
bless the soul kind of like a kanye
situation where like i get to do
whatever i want
in the realms of like specifically not
being asked and to do
uh or being asked consistently of like
what this
is it's like you can google it everyone
has like the same amount of information
but i feel like as well still being on
like the mcdonald's and bugs life
situation just being able to do whatever
i want without anyone asking you
how to do it or why i'm doing it i think
that freedom uh for me as a director is
theaters really moving towards wanting
to uplift the stories of black voices
without
posturing and uh being more concerned
with the monetization of black stories
and seeing how valuable that is in their
season
and i think that that starts with you
know if these theaters want to accept us
and invite
us in and then you know you sit in these
meetings they're like i don't understand
what's going on of course you don't
understand what's going on and
not having to go through that barrier of
having to explain well
in black culture this means this and the
black people in the audience are going
to understand this i think that by
having to educate and prove
um in a way having to prove and justify
blackness to white people
is like extremely violent um and i think
that that happens
very often and i think that if if these
institutions aren't going to give the
latitude
for black people to use their voices
as vocally as they can and the only way
that black people can give their voices
as vocally as they can is if it's as far
away from his proximity to whiteness as
possible so of course
you know there are going to be things
that white people don't understand that
are going on in these black plays
i think institutions i know institutions
have to let
go of that and that's when the real
beginnings of things are going to start
to happen but that is still
policing coming in and making having to
to explain to someone having to explain
to a white person
why this moment matters or what this
means because that institution is who is
an employee
that is policing and if you are really
about your edi
if you're really about the work that
you're doing if you're really about
uplifting these stories
then then then go out of the room and
let it happen because it's not going to
happen
your presence is not going to contribute
in a in a
in a wholly global way to the uplifting
of black voices in the way that i think
that
um a lot of institutions assume
based off of pedagogy that it will
wow thanks y'all i'm blown away i moved
to tears
and um you're right i love tater tots
you know it's just
something about them so there's freedom
in that but i don't think my
nutritionist would approve
me just eating tater tots uh such a
complicated life we have in present day
um thank you all so much for your time
um i
invite the audience to please type your
questions
um on the q a function we have one
already so i'm going to start it off
with that
um from nicole nelson thank you for your
question
but in the meantime feel free to just
use the q a function
to type your question and then um
we'll answer it so nicole nelson asked
um this is for ak payne's play
where pathways meet did you create this
play
as a way for the promises of the civil
rights movement
to intersect with the space race between
the u.s
and the soviet union so that your
african-american characters
could benefit from both events as acts
of black liberation well nicole i love
this closely
thank you
um so yeah one of the big things i love
about playwriting is that there's like
so many different things that are added
onto it like
when you're creating so like yeah i
didn't think of this when i was writing
this
and i think that like it's really
exciting that that's a take that you
have for it and i think that
that's relevant to the sort of
storytelling that i was interested in of
just like how we imagine freedom for
ourselves
um and how we how we have been a part of
these histories
um yeah so thank you for that question
and
i think that there's a lot of different
i think that where pathways me is a
piece that
i'm actively asking questions about all
the time because there's so many
different metaphors and in traffic so
much in metaphor so
a lot of things that i think can exist
within it and exist
yeah in tandem with it so thank you
okay so we have a question from
joni thanks hunt um thank you for this
question joni
um and they would like to know how does
it feel to be free to express who you
are
as a vibrant vibrant picture of black
love
for our culture
and maybe an additional question
to tack onto that is do you feel free
um and if you do how does that feel and
if you don't
how does that feel
um i mean when i do these works i feel
free
i i know that like a big thing for
for for me this uh summer was to like
really be able to immerse myself in
black work
and just
just live in it they'll there's
sometimes we would finish rehearsal and
there's this
when you shut your computer and you no
longer have the people around you that
lingering feeling that you have
out after a rehearsal where things have
set and marinated and you are in this
soup of stuff
together it's just like you're in it by
yourself and it has it like you
sometimes i have to take some time to
just
i don't know like take a walk or uh
listen to some
um sade or something so that i could
just
you know because it it it it becomes
part of you
a part of me is mini a part of me is
rosina
right there's a there's a part of me
that is all these characters
and um uh
you they can't leave you in a way but
but
if you want to like really immerse
yourself in the work if you really want
to soak in it
you know um you take the time that you
have to just
i am with i am with the playwright's
words and
i am the actor trying to just marinate
in this like life
that i'm living in um even if i have to
like
close the computer afterwards and like
be by myself it hurts but it also is
like
fulfilling in a way
if that answer the question
we're going to move on just because
y'all are coming with
beautiful questions so thank you
catherine g
he love you so much catherine chihi
captain chi he acts
um could the two playwrights on the call
aka and angie
mention a few of the writers who have
inspired their plays
do you two identify yourselves um in
these works
do they identify themselves in these
works as part of a tradition of black
writers whom they admire
and uh gloria majou majule who wrote
blessings is not on the call
unfortunately but she's here with us in
spirit
um but are two lovely prairies
who are here if you want mine answering
so basically
um do you identify and do you see
yourself a part of a tradition
of black
um yeah so definitely um i think for
this particular piece
i really look to like so am not bc
phillip she's a poet who i love
um and so christina sharp as well uh
robin bg kelly
i would list the beginning of the play
that i'm reading right now um
and um also some musicians so like sonra
nina simone and prince and minnie evans
who
is a visual artist um i think that
i really try to locate my work and my
storytelling in like the black radical
tradition
um because i feel like that there's a
lot of potential in there to imagine new
worlds and new land for ourselves
and yeah but thank you for that question
uh a question from madame we love that
um
i definitely do think i um and in the
tradition of
the black arts movement that was started
in the 70s a lot of my uh
family members are like black
intellectuals and artists so they were
basically like
transplants with that movement so
growing up i've definitely heard a lot
of like the conversations of what it was
like to be in that movement in terms of
black liberation but also in terms of
like
freedom of expression and humor and
comedy not necessarily in terms of like
the paint those of what it is to be a
part of black life but what is it to be
happy
and so i think the the writings that i
actually look to a lot for at least for
daughters of confederacy wasn't really a
lot for playwrights was actually from a
lot of like
1970s 80s 90s like black comedy
comedians like i was listening to a lot
of
uh richard pryor a lot of listening to a
lot of like um
older dave chappelle and chris rock and
i think a lot of the times we don't
really consider stand-up comedians as
writers because
we don't really see them in the writing
process we're usually watching them in
like the stamina
of what it is to put on performance but
i think for me
listening and then also just hearing the
the words of what these artists were
saying was actually very important of
like a lot of the texts that was
actually being spoken to of like the
delivery the rhythm and the timing
and also just like what are they saying
in terms of the pathos i think one part
in
the rehearsal process we had like i just
sent them uh
everyone like a list of like things that
like i loved in terms of black comment
like i showed like leslie jones and like
uh
uh like more like richard pryor and i
said uh and i think we were having that
conversation of what it is to deal with
trauma and how that
how do we laugh at it and i was like oh
we just have to listen to like richard
pryor's a bit about how he lit himself
on fire
uh freebasing on cocaine like i heard
that in high school and i was like this
is the funniest thing i've ever heard in
my life but it was also very very tragic
at like the very
minimal part of like his whole life so i
guess like a lot of like the things that
i'm very invested in have always been
in the realms of comedy like i
definitely was influenced by george c
wolf
uh the color museum um a lot of like uh
black writers who may have not like be
known in terms of like the
the white consciousness if you will but
i definitely do think that
those and also listening to like family
members and listening to like
so many intricate parts of like black
life has definitely influenced like uh
daughters and retrospect and also
growing up in the south
that's fun
um i love both of these answers and
angie specifically i think that the
conversation about
comedy and blackness really needs to be
at the forefront
of like people's consciousness because i
think there's something really
greek about the extremes of comedy and
tragedy that
just coalesce to form a lot of what
black life is in america
um and shout out to ak's reading list
because i'm working through it right now
um and it is changing a lot of my
thought processes
um so we have a question from
anonymous attendees and uh
they would like to hear from the
playwrights again sorry y'all
um and they're asking um
after seeing your work performed in this
way via zoom
are there any aspects of your work that
stood out or rang differently
than you had originally expected
i can go uh it's funny because like
earlier this morning today i
was watching like these zoom like uh
table reads of like tv shows like
they'll just all come together and they
do like table reads of like old episodes
so i was watching one for community
and it was so funny because like the
episode that they were doing was like an
episode i've seen before
but i think it was so hilarious because
i was still dying
in my like kitchen listening to it
because i was just literally
hearing like the writing and the joke
writing and like the delivery of the
timing of the actors
and even without like the visual element
of like seeing them doing it in the
episode
still made it for me and i think that's
actually something that i witnessed a
lot within the rehearsal space
with daughters was like i like hearing
like the thing out loud
even if it was overzoom and letting the
actors go and letting like christopher
uh take over the reigns of what that was
i think was like a very enjoyable
experience for me
um i don't particularly like enjoy
listening to my words sorry i don't like
listening to my words out loud
specifically when it's being read for
the first time because it's always that
journey of like okay like we're gonna
figure out like
what world that we're in but i feel like
immediately like when we started it was
like the same kind of like intensity i
like just listening to like this old
community episode like i heard when i
was in high school to like now i'm like
oh this is still
like funny and i'm like i hate like
listening to like things i write like oh
that's a joke did it i was like oh but
this is great because seeing them go
even on a uh on zoom was still
exciting for me honestly and i think
that's just kind of like the thing of
you know we're alone in our houses
majority of the time or at least like
for me like i'm living by myself so like
like hearing people like out loud like
in the space that is in mind feels more
intimate
and it feels like more uh like oh like
it's kind of like still the same aspect
of
not trying to uh put the two mediums
together like tv and like theater but
it's like
oh you're in my living room and i feel
kind of like invited to like feeling
that i'm there and
with that it makes it even more you know
intimate in the same way that i would be
in theater where i'm like y'all are like
really like this in front of me and then
y'all i can literally see the spit
that y'all having all the way through
like so there's a different levels of
intimacy that i definitely
notice within this process that i
thought was actually really exciting to
see
pandemic and all yeah and i'll echo i
think the intimacy thing was a huge part
for me because i think there are a lot
of really quiet scenes especially
between minnie and dwight
in in this particular play where it like
they're opened up something for me and
seeing it
seeing it on zoom because of the sort of
closeness that we were able to employ in
that
um and that in that um abigail and shaun
were able to embody
um and i think that in that too
like i think that the core of theater is
imagining what what isn't there of
course and like imagine like imagining
beyond and so
in this particular uh zoom performance
because we didn't have like we
everything is imagined because we're
just like looking at each other
um i think that there was even more room
for the imagination
in that um which i think was really
freeing uh in terms of like just being
able to
to just leave everything open like what
does freedom mean to you uh and that
that being able to change according to
who's watching it and bearing witness in
a new way
thank you we have comments left we're
going to read them aloud because
we love affirmation so we have a comment
from
dr james pilato who's a yale summer
cabaret board member so thank you so
much for your support
james said uh zoom productions
definitely feel like theater
not film yet the focus on such close-up
visions of the performers
gives even more than a front-row seat to
subtle expressions
and nuances of acting it is an
interesting hybrid of stage
and video thanks for the great
performances
to each of you dr jim prolado thank you
so much for that
comment yeah it's it's it's a weird
liminal space to be in you know but
we're doing the best we can we're making
it work
um so this next comment uh made me laugh
uh and i see i see perhaps
anonymous because these are my exact
thoughts um but this person said
i am so very proud of all of you
detective
playwright did you know that the officer
was guilty
mama thank you for getting justice next
time pay someone else to do it
advice to take to the bank
um amazing um
thank you all so much i guess i have one
question for
liam and edmund um thank you so much for
rocking with us on this call um and
thank you
i guess what was it like for you making
those technical decisions
where were those design decisions or
you know stage management decisions to
have them enter
a certain way or in a certain time or
come in on a certain
kind of music we always love hearing um
what it's like to cook up on the back
end
liam i'll let you take this and then
i'll answer okay cool
um it's it's a really interesting
um designing sound for zoom so i'm just
gonna take one of my headphones off
because otherwise i sound weird in my
head
um it's really interesting designing for
zoom um
all the kind of so many of the tricks
you get used to in
um live theater like you know sounds
coming from different spaces sounds kind
of coming in under like a speech and
supporting an actor's voice
all of those things are like totally
thwarted by zoom um
you know you can't have multiple sounds
playing at the same time you can't have
sound come from different directions
so you really have to be very very
specific
um and very kind of like essential in
the choices you make
um which i think leads to a really
uh
i don't know can can lead to some really
interesting
you know ways of sonic storytelling um
so in terms of process
um basically i had conversations with
with christopher and with alex
and we would talk about the kind of
sound needs for the show
and yeah just the way to kind of support
that and and to kind of execute those
decisions and
and tell the story in usually like the
simplest
and most concise and often quickest way
that we could
um sonically to just try and like you
know
to to tell the story and to like aid in
the telling of the story but
like i just been alluded to before like
the text is really the carrier
um of the pace in this format and so to
really not interfere with the text
um or do it you know to interview as
little as possible
uh and i think uh on my end
it was definitely different this is
definitely a different experience about
a solid 85 to 90 percent of the things
that i would
normally do doesn't exist in the realm
of
in zoom theater so it was a lot of also
reinterrogating and re-examining who i
am and these processes and the space
when
uh working as individuals which was
really nice is
almost everyone um that worked on these
shows this summer were
someone that i had already worked with
um so for me it was more of just
continuing that connection with people
that i have already worked with and
engaged with
um and definitely filled a sense of
community and those things that we've
been missing since
uh covet started and all the craziness
but it's uh
definitely been nice to
be able to just be a part of sitting
back and
listening and watching and kind of
engaging in the text like everyone has
been saying
um because i'm not spending all this
time figuring out
um when these like cues are gonna happen
or when sound
isn't gonna happen or how entrances and
exits or costume changes are gonna
happen um
and i definitely feel like over these
last three weeks i've been so much more
connected and engaged with
the conversations that are happening in
the room and in the space and
what the text is actually saying um
instead of having to kind of be split
focused on yes i'm hearing this point
because this is really
great and creative but also how do i
make sure
that this vision of the scene comes
together logistically or have we asked
these questions of these different
departments or
am i taking notes about these things and
i was really able to
sit back and let um
let the artists work and then also just
sit back and enjoy watching the artists
work
and in ways that i don't normally get to
do when i'm sitting
behind a table in the rehearsal room so
that part was fun
definitely it was hard not having
personal connection time uh it's weird
when we go on a break and normally i
would walk around and check in with
people on breaks and see how things are
going and
uh talk about daily life and stuff like
that and then set on zoom
break means everyone turns their cameras
off meets their mics and walks away for
10 to 15 minutes and it's
um a much more disconnecting than we're
used to in the actual rehearsal rooms
but eventually i think we'll figure out
ways to
make sure that that community aspect of
it still stays
um so one of the recent comments that we
got
is actually for you liam um and it says
that
the church organ music was powerful and
eerie
um and i just wanted to just give you a
special shout out for all of your work
that you did especially when you were
moving um
and say how grateful we are for you and
your arsenal
of fire sounds um
what can we say we're trying to burn
everything to the ground
um and edmund i also wanted to say thank
you to you for your sense of humor
um and for your continuous wonderful
emails that tell us everything we need
to know the night before
um so if there are
since there are no other questions i
want to take this opportunity to thank
um the misa sponsors um and the
leadership team
uh for putting together such an
interesting and
necessary season um we love you and
we're grateful for all of your work
um and we also of course want to thank
our audience because without you
there would be nothing you would just be
in the abyss which we kind of already
are
um so thank you everyone
for coming um and we hope that you have
a good night